Boy Meets White Nights
at your service sir
I'm a little five white knight Jesus
Christ I'm only like a level three
paladin tonight
Squire if you study what I know you will
be able to be on my level so women okay
I respect women so much I wish I was one
tear to my eye
let's review the white knight ready by
the end of this video
perhaps you who's watching as well could
become a fellow of white knight and
protect women all over the planet
respect woman's this one says George
Lopez with a sweet and simple response
George Lopez you should go back to
Mexico you are bullying and swearing
[Music]
who's the white knight here those could
be George Lopez yeah I'm confused
yeah I think it I think it's people
trying to - white knight people and then
just be I have it though back in their
face this guy was so proud of this
Hillary Clinton me me signed and dated
it fools no man
fools no man can defeat me I am no man
Nick Bell 2016 this that's beautiful
Nick Bell twin so glad I think we should
start doing that and all memes put it
but it's only missing the copyrights
yeah yeah you gotta put your water marks
and all memes so they know that you
originally stole it oh Jesus I thought
it was jacksepticeye oh you know only a
true white knight can pull up that face
you need to be at least level 10 the
face of smugness and
at the same time their face you make
when oh I wasn't wrong that's literally
what it says your gender is responsible
for the oppression of women for
centuries and your race is responsible
for the enslavement of people of color
around the globe
and your nation is responsible for the
attempted war of Muslim people were
crowned worldwide and you realize it's
sorry
[Music]
they said you pull off their I need to
take some bad stuff just post a selfie
either post a selfie and skip the text
all right
either push the selfie or the text okay
do you combine both and I hate you is
this guy sitting in first class right
now while he's taking the selfie okay oh
look it's matpat male feminist wondering
how long does he have to agree with
women until he gets laid I can't tell if
it has to be satire I'm also not sure
[Laughter]
Jimmy's seafood is savaged today oh god
I love the company being savaged good
morning Peter
crab emoji ah childish taunts are good
for business apparently look we don't
give you hair advice and you won't give
us business advice cool cool yo yo
Jimmy's let's be real for a moment Megan
Tara's super rad so trying to make a
joke about her hair is lame Al and his
2008 team bro 2018
can we nuttin can we add chilli nut and
they'd just be besties and for once
again her hair is super rad
your friend Kip I cannot stress that
enough her hair is super rad
hashtag BFF hashtag besties hashtags
thirsty no she's still not gonna date
you know J Griffith Oh rad effort right
a forever
I can't believe see me Jimmy Seaford
came out of winner that one cuz I feel
like taunting PJ so cringy at this point
all your girlfriend wants on a Sunday is
for you to take her to brunch while
wearing yoga pant a punny t-shirt
oversized sunglasses her hair in a big
effed up bun and for you not to talk to
her while she's close to her boat look
at what a gorgeous mess he is you don't
deserve her so be a man drive her to
brunch gaze at her adoringly but keep
your freaking mouth shut while she
catches up on last night's happenings
pay the check and maybe she won't figure
out she's way out of your league Jesus
Christ why do men always have to shop
women from scar lanes that too much to
ask to look at them dankmemes that being
interrupted
smh crying shaking my hands so hard
right now ken shook shook i'm woke I'm
shucking em why isn't it called no
woman's sky
the real question hmm free chicken why
why is it not come ramming sky oh oh
okay you made it finally God I'm ready
famous guys the comments keep
excessively harassing her and Twitter
will permanently ban you you have been
reporting
Khadem male entitlement knows no is the
rest of us keep going bad
you'll get lead one day for your thighs
legs and breasts cinders is ass to KFC
your women not a value menu yeah this
guy gets it does he live inside an
orange you disrespect my lady in the
wrong neighborhood Chad
damn damn the fedoras
oh and that lien oh yeah the one leg up
they bought the bus sounds like a music
video why did the fedora become such a
staple for virginity brand new dress
never worn because it's too big for me
fit size 10 to 14 super stretchy
material 20 bucks
Leo would smash Leo's about to just get
completely annihilated
here comes Benjy in though with the save
what exactly do you mean by that are you
trying to say that you would have sex
with this women that is growth uh-huh
that is gross than the gross way of
saying it seriously you're pathetic
Ellen I think you were forgetting at it
that no you wouldn't smash this woman is
probably so far out of your league you
wouldn't even touch backs I'm not a
viewer stalking big Bill's saying stuff
like that what the most intimate the
human contact you receive lately is
using the public toilet when the seat is
still warm public thought enjoy your
little PS beautiful dress smiley face
Sara replies hey Jory you're Benji right
back at you my love o it comes real he's
mad Leo back ok excuse me Ben I'm sorry
you took my comment serious I understand
the purpose of your comment was to win
female approval at the expense of your
dignity so I'm not particularly offended
wow this is I mean they're both cringy
in my opinion now god damn it
girls are so freakin two-faced and yes
I'm gonna tack her before anybody else
does it so among my many talents I love
to bake which I was doing today
he loves to bake oh I thought say it to
myself hmm you know would be nice
making extra muffins and bringing them
round two blinks house no girl's house
okay nope nope apparently not
you are a you were so rude and
ungrateful oh he was gonna make your
extra muffins how could you you didn't
even invite me in accept my present
which I've gone to extra effort to make
all I want is douchebags not caring for
men like me haha don't take it
personally you'll be sweet not very fair
posting this on public status and you
should be home her instead just giving
advice thumbs up no hate but if someone
does me wrong the last thing I'm good at
all right your call dude I can finally
call you out on your beers you came to
my house whilst I was with my boyfriend
Oh which you've known about for ages but
still act like a desperate weirdo trying
to get me to go out with you I don't see
how it's to make knew you had to be if
please a douche and I'm just saying you
deserve better
but what do I know haha
and just cause someone has a BF doesn't
mean another guy can't have a chance
with the person I wasn't trying the guy
can still get a chance and swoop in and
steal you with with thongs condoms and
extra muffins I wasn't trying on my
French god damn it I wasn't trying to be
your bf just trying to have a chance you
surprised the old cupcakes and condoms
sweetie didn't work something wrong with
that girl
yeah I mean the ball friend could have
Ward the thong what a journey
emotional roller coaster how the white
armor works
please hog 'native dissonance helmet
allows rad femme dogma to make sense to
him it also corrects his male gaze
that's right eye contact is very
important he's got the magic breastplate
that allows him to swallow his pride and
check his privilege get the soap the
soap the SJW sword cuts new entitlement
like hot knife through butter
protective knee pads protects his knees
when groveling at the feet of the
nearest women while apologizing on
behalf of all men
I'm a Jackson my beds oh there it is
again we have now joined we have become
what we hated ken what has happened to
you God has come full circle o male
family speed a slight breeze and the old
disappeared it's a male feminist meetup
F FEMA comes in hey guys can I join no
famine history is the round table
meeting the white knights are here
that's a white knight
it is our duty to stand up and respect
women worldwide smash like if you
respect women and for more info on women
check out this is a it was confusing
shout out ever received but thank you
there you go kid